hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about two cell structures plasmodesmata
and gap junctions and while they have
definite differences in structure they
are very similar in function so let's
talk about that function why are these
cell structures important well in
multicellular organisms like plants
mammals cells must be able to
communicate with each other and this
cell to cell communication is really
important for the multicellular
organisms to be able to function as one
unit the cells must be able to talk back
and forth to work together in order to
keep the organism healthy and functional
so plasmodesmata and gap junctions both
facilitate cell to cell communication
just in different types of organisms
plasmodesmata are in plant cells and gap
junctions are in animal cells so let's
look at these different structures first
I've drawn two plant cells here we've
got the cell wall in brain surrounding
the plasma membrane in red I've also
drawn in the nucleus of each cell in
blue and for the sake of simplicity I've
left out several other important
organelles things like mitochondria
chloroplasts the central vacuole are not
pictured here but what else is pictured
is this channel heater you can see that
the plasma membrane of one cell connects
to the plasma membrane of the
neighboring cell through essentially a
hole in the cell walls this channel
right here is called a plasma Dez month
that is the
singular form of plasmodesmata
plasmodesmata refers to two or more
plasmodesmata
now let's look at gap junctions here we
have two animal cells the plasma
membrane in red the nucleus in blue
again I've left out several other
organelles but notice what is connecting
the two cells there are these proteins
that assemble to form a complex that
allows them to connect the two cells
these proteins are called connections
and they form a transmembrane structure
that is they're inserted on either end
into two different plasma membranes and
the proteins themselves have a channel
in between them and that channel is
called the gap Junction so even though
we have different structural features
where one is actually a continuous cell
membrane and the other we have separate
plasma membranes but connected with
these proteins called connections still
both plasmodesmata and gap junctions
allow two important things to move
between cells those are ions and other
small molecules
and this is these ions and small
molecules that act as signaling factors
where one cell can send them to the
other cell in order to relay a specific
message and this results in some kind of
cellular response so that is how
plasmodesmata and gap junctions work and
that is it today at biology professor
thank you for watching and I hope you
learned a lot